previous earlier on the show
I talked to you about how this week's
Trump Russia house investigation
suddenly canceled all hearings the
obvious question is why one possibility
is that it was meant to prevent Sally
Yates from testifying if you don't
remember Sally Yates she was the
Attorney General for the last couple of
years under President Obama and for a
few days under Donald Trump she was
supposed to testify this week and
there's a Washington Post report out
saying that the White House didn't want
her to testify and that that's what's
behind the canceled panel meetings this
week and as Acting Attorney General
Yates played a key part in that
investigation surrounding Michael Flynn
who ultimately did resigned in total
shame after admitting that he had lied
about his meetings with the Russian
ambassador Sergei Kiss lyac Yates and
another witness former CIA director John
Brennan made clear to the government
that their testimony would probably I
love the wording on this it would
probably contradict some statements made
by White House officials that's not
something that Donny boy Trump is going
to like and the White House position on
the allegations that they tried to block
Yates from testified is visit you you
have to pay attention to the words here
to understand what's going on asked
about the allegation from the Washington
Post that the White House tried to stop
Sally Yates from testifying the White
House said quote the White House has
taken no action to prevent Sally Yates
from testifying okay we've got to focus
on has taken no action that is
meaningless language all that could mean
is that the White House didn't formally
take any action but they could have
communicated in any number of ways that
they didn't want her to testify and that
it's really a bad idea for her to
testify the most likely scenario is that
the Trump White House sort of
bureaucratically and somewhat
diplomatically tried to dissuade her
from testifying or try to make others
prevent her from testifying and that
didn't work so then Devin Nunez went and
cancelled the hearings along with all
the other scheduled meetings but I love
that we've taken no action
is a very specific meaning and you could
take no formal action and still make it
clear that Sally Yates had better not
testify it's just playing around with
words and remember Sally Yates was fired
as Acting Attorney General by Donald
Trump when she refused to enforce his
original travel ban right the thing is
Donald Trump used to be able to get away
with firing people and not really face
any backlash now that he's in the
government the people that he's firing
people Excel Yates Michael Flynn they
may have dirt on him and this is why
early on when it was clear that Donald
Trump started antagonizing the
intelligence community I said you know
Donald the more it becomes clear that
the Intel community has on you the more
you should probably avoid going to war
with them merely for self-preservation
because it's abundantly clear that the
more you antagonize them the more likely
it is that they're going to put out the
information that they have and in a way
it has sort of happened and part of it
has been that their hand has been forced
they just in having to contradict the
lies of Trump it's brought out many
intel community individuals to say yeah
what Donald Trump is saying is wrong and
this is the same thing when we talk
about fighting the media when Donald
Trump starts going after all sorts of
media outlets as fake news that can also
be dangerous for him because it's clear
that these media outlets know stuff that
they could publish and remember the
Washington Post brought down Richard
Nixon and we also have been drawing a
lot of comparisons to the former FBI
director J Edgar Hoover yeah no one was
willing to fire him because every
president realized this guy could get
the best of me yes no doubt about it and
and I think that to a small degree or to
some degree we're already seeing that
and it could get way worse in the next
couple of weeks to month